[Music]
all right let's go out to Minnesota and
talk to T money what's up
Tracy hi Dr John what's
happening uh just working um little my
wrist
bet how we doing well um okay um so I
wrote Into the show um and the question
I wrote in is how do I tell my husband I
don't believe in him and I can't support
his
dreams um I know that sounds terrible
say that's a hot
take hot
take so here's the backstory okay uh
we've been married for eight years we
have three kids ages 7
six5 um prior to getting married um you
know my husband was very responsible
with money he didn't have any debt he
worked fulltime he always had other jobs
Hobbies things he was working on he was
busy all the time um after a first child
was born he wanted to start his own
business and I supported him with that
he's very smart he's very skilled he can
do just about anything Plumbing building
working on engines basically anything
with his hand hold on hold on this is
awesome
because because he can build things
doesn't mean he can run a business
right yes yes yeah it's all like dude
education to run a business I am great
at barbecue I should open a barbecue
restaurant it's like those are two
different things ohy boy okay so he
started like a mechanic shop or handyman
business or something a landscaping
business Landscaping all right and he
probably just got a like a spreadsheet
or a piece of paper and wrote down like
this many Lawns times this we're going
to be rich and you were like
sweet yeah kind of yeah all right then
life happened all right so then what
yeah well he's a perfectionist so
everything always takes him 10 times
longer than it would somebody else if he
can even stay on task and finish it
struggles with anxiety okay and ADHD I
don't know anything about those two
things so continue I know you
don't um and about six years ago he
started drinking as a way to deal with
the anxiety and stress from his business
yeah um I guess in my opinion I feel
like he prioritizes work over family and
I've basically been a single mom this
entire
time um you know examples like being two
months pregnant with her second child
I've got a six-month old at home and
I've got the flu and his response is
well I've got to go to work well you're
self-employed you can't take the day off
nope
um you know that's the
um um sacrifice you have to make when
you start a business if you want to
succeed is you just have to work all the
time 16 hour days seven days a
week um but currently um our situation
is is that we own a 15 acre fixer upper
hobby farm and there's a lot of debt
between that and his business um but now
he wants to turn it into a small
development not that he knows how to be
a developer um build and sell houses on
it and I don't feel like I can support
that um the appraisal came back that
it's basically worth twice what we paid
for it um and he thinks he can just take
out more loans to pay himself we're at
the Tipping Point where we can't barely
make the payments and his response is to
take more money out to pay the
payments all of this while he's still
drinking um you know he's alcoholic um
he can't get things done timely he can't
stay on task and then he has more
anxiety because he's behind and so he
drinks more um accuses me not believing
in him but he's right I don't you know I
don't trust him I don't I just don't
think this is ever going to happen and I
don't know like how to have this
conversation with him without it
sounding like an ultimatum I think
you're at
ultimatum I think you're I have I've
tried I've been there yeah but you
weren't
serious you already I don't know what my
ultimatum is you tell me
I mean I've I've threatened divorce and
haven't walked away I mean I mean that's
the nuclear
option you're y'all aren't addressing
the core issue here and I think the core
issue here is your husband's clearly got
some emotional health challenges that he
hasn't dealt with he doesn't know how to
be married to a woman with three kids he
doesn't know how to parent three kids
what he does know how to do is
incredible Landscaping work when he
shows
up and so he goes to the places where
he's
reinforced he's also probably talks to a
bunch of knuckleheaded dudes and watch
lots of YouTube about how just take your
land and Flip It and Roll It Roll it and
flip it and take a second mortgage and
then he lock that one and then triple
stamp a double stamp and he talked to a
couple of buddies and they're like yeah
dude
yeah and that's where he gets
reinforcement yep and then you come home
University do what I call it YouTube
University there you go it's always been
YouTube there you
go which has some cool things you can
learn how to fix a thing at your house
and you can learn some
information but
man Michael Jordan didn't YouTube his uh
well he was he was not playing then I'm
trying to think
um um LeBron James doesn't YouTube his
nutrition stuff he hires a nutritionist
and he doesn't YouTube his exercise
program he has a personal trainer guys
who are successful don't YouTube The
Depths right they might YouTube how to
fix a door handle all that doesn't
matter he's your husband's not on the
phone with me right now the question I
have before you is how long are you
going to stay on this
ride and there are places to get off
before
divorce how many of these things have
you co-signed
on um because of the state we live in I
have had to co-sign on everything
okay even though none of it's in my
name what if you started today saying I
will never cosign another thing again
perod I have already said that
okay and if he signs your name does he
have power of attorney over you no okay
if he signs your name then you tell him
I'm going to call the police and say you
fraudulently signed my name I'm G call a
bank has he done that no and he wouldn't
okay but this isn't about money and this
isn't about your hobby farm and this
isn't about
development this is about your
marriage I mean Hanging On by a by like
dancing on a razor blade mhm what scares
you about having that conversation do
you think he's just going to walk out
the
door I don't do well a confrontation I
feel like any time I try to confront him
about anything I lose the argument just
because he gets angry and he yells and I
basically just shut down okay so I just
don't feel like I can even have the
conversation we've tried some marriage
counseling it didn't really go anywhere
refuses to go back you know I've talked
to him about the drinking he says yes
it's a problem I'll get help when well
when this is done when that is done well
nothing's ever going to be done and I
know it's just a phrase he's using so
you have to decide okay what I've done
isn't
working I'm going to do something
different to protect me and my three
children because my husband has chosen
not to protect them or to protect
us I'm going to stop engaging in tit
fortat back and forth conversations
instead I'm going to write down down and
I'm going to give him a copy and slide
it across the table after I read it to
him not before otherwise he won't listen
to you he'll just start reading and
say I can't live like this
anymore I feel incredibly
unsafe your addiction is out of control
your unwillingness to deal with your
emotional health is out of control when
he starts yelling say I'm not going to
engage in a back and forth not today we
can later but not today and tell them if
you yell I'm going to get up and
leave if you start going back and forth
I'm going to get up and leave will he at
least listen to you if you sat down and
had a conversation with
him I don't know anymore okay I mean I
also think he has more mental health
needs that I'm aware of you know and
sometimes I can't tell if it's that or
if it's the drinking I can't even tell
always when he's been drinking anymore
um the last conversation I tried to have
with him about something like this
I mean he acted like he was psychotic
I'm punching walls um but he sore he
hadn't been drinking so I I don't know
like I don't know if there's something
else there but he won't go in and get
evaluated he says I'm not going to pay
somebody he feels like
it's the most ridiculous quote ever but
he he said it's like paying for sex to
go to a therapist I'm not going to pay
somebody for that
H just it's a strange correlation that I
wouldn't make but that's cool
so you've probably heard me say this on
the show but whenever I'm sitting down
and talking to someone like you I always
want to look at
Trends and this feels like over the last
five or six years this has just
continued to escalate in really um
unsafe
direction from hey I'm going to quit my
great job and I'm going to I'm going to
strike out on my own to it's not working
out quite as I as much as I thought and
I'm incredible at my work but I'm not a
great boss especially of myself and I
don't have the discipline and then the
the nerves kick in and the anxiety kicks
in and the scatter brain kicks in and
trying to keep up with the call that
just came in on a piece of paper and I
can't find that paper but I'm supposed
to be somewhere all that stuff and the
one thing that shuts off those alarms is
alcohol to a few years later now he's
punching holes through
walls so my question for you is when and
where does this end what's your
line what's your or
what and more not more importantly but
equally importantly is what's that line
for your
kids
um gosh I just I don't know
anymore you're Outsourcing that to him
he doesn't get a vote right this second
I'm asking
you if you were in a classroom at your
local church and a man walked in and
started screaming and punching hole
Holes through walls What would would you
do W immediately
right if someone had taken your home
finances and made it such a precarious
situation that the chances of you having
a home to live in this time next
year are very
small what would you
do I've kind of already done it we we
are separated right now because of the
weird situation we got ourselves into
with this farm and we sold our house
last year me and the kids are living
with my mom and he's living out at the
farm by himself okay what I have told
him is that I will not move back in
there until you've gotten treatment so
I'm stuck kind of in this limbo point of
waiting for him to get treatment while
he's finishing this house out there for
us to live in maybe that I've told him
I'm not going to move into if he doesn't
get treatment is he going to get
treatment he says he's going to when the
house is
done so his wife and his three kids
y'all just hang
on I'm GNA do whatever it is I want to
do whenever I want to do it y'all just
y'all just wait at your mom's
house yeah that's the current
situation and with the money as bad as
it is like I could try I talked to a
divorce lawyer and I but I I just feel
so stuck with the money that if I were
to divorce him there's I'm I'm walking
away negative I mean we both
are I don't even know how to I mean I'm
definitely not getting out of my mom's
house at that point then I don't think
you're getting out of your mom's house
for a long long
time and my guess is if I had to fast
forward a year you have three young kids
and you had a picture of what this was
going to be you married an amazing guy
who went to work and kicked butt and was
there for you and those younger kids as
they were starting to be born and for a
number of
reasons he has taken a totally different
path and so your picture of what was
going to be is now very very different
you never pictured yourself being a
single mom with three kids living back
with your mother you never pictured
yourself going back to work full-time
which is what you're going to have to do
oh I've been working fulltime the whole
time okay all right good for you I'm the
one that supports the family good for
you I have the health
insurance okay you have all of the Power
here you put food in his fridge you got
health insurance for
him you have all of it and your veiled
threats simply haven't
worked and I think there's a reckoning
of I got to deal with reality he will
not he he cares more about this project
than he does me and the kids Behavior a
language he cares more about trying to
figure out another scheme and another
scheme or let's just say he's really
sick and he simply won't go to the
doctor that's probably my biggest fear
like I feel like if we could get over
that
hurdle maybe some of the rest of it
would work out a little but you just
said we the conversation you said we and
that's not how it
works right he has to
decide and it sounds like he's willing
to lose his family before he goes and
gets the help he
needs does that sound
right well shoot he already has lost Jo
he already moved out yeah it seems that
way yeah he he talks differently but his
actions are that would he meet you in a
restaurant not at the house not at your
mother-in-law's house but just you two
at a restaurant
yeah and just ask him hey I need to I
need to know what the deal is or put it
this way you got 30 days to go or I'm
going to have to make some different
decisions because I need to know whether
I need to get an apartment for these
kids or if we need to just make my mom's
house permanent for a while for a season
while I can save up some money I got to
figure out how bad the finances are and
we're going to a divorce attorney's
going to have to do all that for
us or are you going to go to the doctor
within the next two
weeks and if he gets up and walks out of
the restaurant then you know
right and if you want to be extra
enabling you can grab uh get three names
of people who he could go see he could
call right
away
but he can consider counseling
prostitution all he wants but you get to
make the
call
okay what do you not like about this
something just doesn't sound right in
your soul is it that you just haven't
come to terms with the reality of the
situation or are you just holding out
because you love him and you want him to
come
back what is it it all feels like stuff
I've kind of already done before like
I've I've tried having the conversation
he's had appointments for counseling for
treatment multiple times that I've
helped him set up and then the day comes
and he just does it go he says no I'm
okay I'm gonna I'll be I'll be so and
then a month later then he's not um and
well then now he knows he doesn't have
to he knows that
now
in fact when you call he's like oh here
we go I got to do the merry go thing
again and then he tells you all the
right things then you leave and he gets
another month or two to do whatever he
wants so it seems like the choices
before you are just to make peace with
this
cycle this is what it is or that
you make some very clear time and date
demands for lack of better terms and he
gets to opt in or opt out I will file on
this date I've already moved out I've
already told you you have to quit being
abusive I've already told you you have
to stop drinking I already told you you
can't take any more money
out you've already wrecked this family
and by the way if you sell the 15 Acres
if it's doubled in value and you drop
the price a little bit to get it sold
y'all can get your your financial
situation cleared
up he's going to go from 15 acres and
building his own house and I'm going to
develop all this he's going to go to one
bedroom apartment but that's the life he
chose but that's really it looks like
that's the only two paths ahead of you
you've done all the leg work you've done
all this stuff you have to decide I'm
not leaving him I'm just
not so I'm just going to be here pling
along giving him health insurance doing
my
life or you're going to be very clear
here's a piece of paper this is my this
is what it's going to take for you this
is how I know you want to stay married
to
me if not then the attorney's going to
call and we'll sell these assets and
we're going to split everything up and
then we're going to go our separate ways
because you clearly are more invested in
this life that you're fantasizing about
than you are about the kids and you are
about
me I don't know many men who wouldn't
take their wife and their three kids
moving out as a huge alarm a five alarm
fire in their
home that's just me thanks for the
call